before this week few had heard a
shepherd of now the Army watches over
this little village soldiers sweep the
rural roads
this is the place the war in Ukraine
spilled over when a missile crossed the
Polish border killing two
we meet stanislav heading to church he
grew up with both the victims when he
heard the explosion he feared the
Russians were coming
foreign
she tells me her house shook she heard
two explosions and saw a cloud of dust
were you frightened yes
Poland the US and NATO think the missile
was most likely astray from Ukrainian
air defenses appoint Ukraine disputes
this father is one of two who died in a
seemingly tragic accident
devastating matesh who found the bodies
how it's possible you go to work and and
you died on the it's
this community is not just feeling lost
but also fear we're just four miles from
the Ukrainian border here and the war is
feeling dangerously close
as this community Grieves it's aware
it's had a lucky escape this time
fighting hasn't crossed the border but
this is a reminder of how easily
conflict can spread Siobhan Robbins Sky
News Eastern Poland